- Do kids ever recognize
you as Buzz Lightyear
'cause your voice?
- What's unusual it's the voice,
and I think Warner Brothers' cartoons
a long time ago told the people
they did not want Mel Blanc
or anybody doing the voice
outside of the cartoon environment,
and I understand why.
I'm in Manhattan in an elevator
and a young kid is misbehaving.
Some kids at certain ages
punch you in the crotch
I don't know what that's about.
- They're yeah and it's--
- There's a certain age
they're right there,
- Always boys.
- They know it gets your attention.
And so this kid was punching mom
in the leg and really going nuts,
so I said to infinity and beyond,
you shouldn't treat your mom like that.
And the kid went,
(laughs)
he looked all around the elevator
and then started crying
and turned into the mom looking at me
like now she's mad.
- At you, and he was punching--
- And the kid goes
that ugly man swallowed Buzz Lightyear.
(laughs)
- Now you can punch him, um I--
- I will say Hanks my
good buddy plays Woody,
but who cares about a cowboy,
he goes, he did a sweet trick for us.
We went to a Children's Hospital together
and we did, and what he did
it was such a wonderful idea,
he has these kids,
close your eyes for a minute.
And when the kids close their eyes
then we can do the voices together,
and then they imagine
Woody and Buzz are there.
- That's so sweet.
- It's much, oh God, he's a great guy,
and I say it was I've learned that lesson.
If anybody wants to hear it,
shut your eyes, especially
little kids little ones.
- Yeah.
Shut your eyes and then
I'll go to near them,
say some Buzz Lightyear stuff
then they don't--
- Don't freak them out in an elevator.
(laughs)